le château de chaumont-sur-loire est
construit sur un mont avec une
perspective magnifique sur la loire il
cache bien d'autres secrets et d
histoire une histoire un peu comme tous
les châteaux de la loire
regardez tout de suite un château à
taille humaine
élégant chaumont à l'époque était un peu
plus grand et ouvert au vent en 1480
viennent s'ajouter le châtelet de
l'entrée et l'escalier d'honneur en 1505
charles xii rend visite au propriétaire
il admire alors la frise renaissance
avec les deux c entrelacés de charles
deux soeurs de chaumont entre ces
dossiers vous avez une montagne en
flammes
ça fonctionne comme un rébus parce qu'à
l'origine et s'il y avait une forêt donc
pour construire le château où il a bien
fallu brûler la forêt des arbres on est
aussi à 40 mètres par rapport au niveau
de la loire sur une sorte de petite
montagne
donc ça fait mon enflammé mont chauve et
si on met à l'envers moncheaux cela fait
tout simplement chaumont autres
personnages marquants catherine de
médicis la reine confronté à une cour
anti italienne la femme d'henry 2,6
superstitieuse était très attaché à ce
petit joyau
même si elle habite à peu catherine 2006
a amené avec elle en france son
raffinement italien la délicatesse dans
laquelle elle avait été élevée puisque
elle avait été remarquablement formés et
donc elle est là comme beaucoup de
personnalité de cette période de la
renaissance données laissé son empreinte
à ce château
la relation de cette grande reine avec
diane de poitiers la favorite du roi
fera d'ailleurs couler beaucoup d'encre
à la main d'henry de son mari qui est
décédé dans un tournoi elle a élégamment
donné ce château qui était le sien à
diane de poitiers
le roi avait été fort généreux avec
diane de pâtes ips qui lui avait donné
le château de chenonceau et avec
beaucoup de subtilité à la reprise selon
so après 1560 foin de la terrasse à ciel
ouvert la nouvelle propriétaire mettra
une toiture sur le chemin de ronde et y
apposera ses armes un carquois et des
flèches mais voici à l'intérieur du
château dans une salle spéciale la salle
du conseil où vous nous accueillez vous
êtes l'hôtesse vous êtes responsable de
ce domaine chantal expliquez-nous un
petit peu la particularité de cette
salle avec des tapisseries cette salle
du conseil est une salle extrêmement
importante dans château et les derniers
propriétaires le prince et la princesse
de brouille avait acheté cette tapissé
exceptionnels de la fin du xvième siècle
qui s'appelle la tenture des planètes
s'étaient jours et c'est un trésor elle
est en huit parties elle a été récemment
restaurée et grâce à la radio et dans
quel état il ya quelques temps et elle a
partie liée avec l'astrologie
il ya tous les signes du zodiaque et
puis les dieux de l'époque romaine et je
vous montrerai par exemple ici venus ici
on a marre c'est ici on est venus
regarder ces scènes merveilleuse de joie
de libations d'amour ces paradis on est
dans un jardin d'ailleurs à chaumont on
a le festival des jardins quel thème du
paradis et le végétal est extrêmement
présent dans cette tapisserie mais si
votre regard se porte vers la droite
vous avez insensiblement des scènes qui
sont quand même moins bucolique
vous avez des gens qui scelle ccyn le
sang coule
les hommes se battent et ça c'est le
dieu mars qui est lié au signe du
scorpion et tout ça extrême à l'autre
on passe d'un extrême à l'autre et tout
ça dans une ambiance extrêmement
extrêmement végétales dont mme
desjardins
c'est une tapisserie exceptionnelle et
d'une immense poète les jardins c'est
particulier un ici et dans le domaine de
chaumont-sur-loire je vous propose de
prendre un petit peu de hauteur avec des
images vues du ciel les images de drones
tourné il ya quelques semaines pour
regarder c'est superbe c'est 32 ha si je
me trompe pas le domaine à une triple
identité une identité patrimoniale on
vient d'en parler une identité
artistique
on va en parler juste après une identité
jardini stick puisque chaque année se
déroule le festival international des
jardins ça aussi on en parlera chantal
et chantal si je vous dis renaissance à
vous fait penser également à léonard de
vinci j'imagine absolument alors léonard
de vinci est connu comme un génial
inventeur si je vous donne
si vous devez me donner une invention
vous me diriez je parlais de
l'hélicoptère ou des automobiles par
exemple l'automobile et bien je vous
propose de découvrir cette invention
avec léonard de vinci
si cet enfant fait le buzz avec sa
voiture toupie c'est grâce à leonard
raccourci certes mais de vinci a tout de
même inventé la première automobile de
l'histoire que l'on nommera plus tard le
chariot autopropulsés
en 2004 on découvre la vérité sur ce
schéma c'est en réalité un accessoire de
scène capable de se déplacer seul et de
transporter des automates en 14 178
léonard de vinci pense la mécanique de
la voiture comme les mouvements
d'horloge
en revanche on les ressort à l'intérieur
des gros tambour l'énergie et emmagasiné
plus relâché dans les engrenages
c'est une cascade de pignons qui avance
d'un cran à chaque fois c'est ce que
l'on appelle le mécanisme des chapons
juste ici ce mécanisme identique à celui
du tout garanti la libération penny
forme de l'énergie à chaque rang donc
sur la longueur c'est tout le contraire
d'une voiture miniature qui elle libère
l'énergie d'un seul coup et hop plus
rien c'est fini chaque temps boas sur la
rotation d'une roue motrice de manière
indépendante
la troisième roue elle commande seul le
chariot qui se déplace sur scène et se
balade et léonard de vinci a une
nouvelle fois révolutionner lmnp
[Musique]
nous parlions d'une identité artistique
chanteuse c'est un centre d'art
également ici à centre d'art est de
nature toutes les oeuvres qui sont
présentées ici ont partie liée avec la
nature vous avez des branches des arbres
du végétal des brumes
c'est le dénominateur commun de toutes
les oeuvres que nous présentons à
l'intérieur et l'extérieur
vous accueillez des artistes
internationaux des artistes organisée
tout au long de l'année on a une saison
d'arc commence fin mars qui terminant en
novembre après on a des photographes
mais toujours en lien avec la nature et
le paysage
quel est le but l'objectif est de mettre
en évidence ce lien avec le paysage avec
la nature et il ya une cohérence
générale dans le domaine ya le festival
des jardins ses oeuvres d'art qui sont
liées aux mouvements du land art mais
également à tout ce qui concerne la
poésie de la relation avec le cosmos et
la nature tout est lié donc à ces
artistes chanteurs je vous propose d'en
choisir un
qu'est-ce qu'on est un artiste gao à
l'organique sinkiang qui présente cette
année ses paysages ses paysages
extraordinaires qui sont entre le rêve
et la réalité entre la figuration et
l'abstraction c'est un immense artiste
qui est aussi prix nobel de littérature
il a tous les talents mobile en 2000 en
l'an 2000
et donc c'est important pour un lieu de
culture de réflexion comme chaumont
d'avoir la présence d'artistes de cette
qualité eh bien on l'a rencontré cet
après midi à regarder tenter de cerner
cet artiste n'est pas une tâche aisée
gaoxing trang est un peintre un écrivain
prix nobel de la littérature en 2000
aulas dît dramaturge metteur en scène
aujourd'hui yahoo vous avez décidé
d'être avec nous merci dans cette
exposition pour faire un appel à la
renaissance à chaumont sur loire c'est
le titre de votre exposition pourquoi
avoir choisi ce titre là c'est vraiment
une
belle chance c'était madame colette
dumont
elle m'a proposé de faire une exposition
dans un château
la première fois le souvenir ici imi
quatre porsche est fasciné par ce beau
lieu de renaissance pour moi c'est un
vrai qu'on te fait te fais une
exposition où je propose le thème se
rappelle pour une nouvelle renaissance
surtout qu'en ce beau lieu de
renaissance ya un message derrière cet
appel à la renaissance un message
politique également
c'est quoi c'est pas vraiment un
portique c'est plutôt culturel parce que
ça c'est je pense à lancer cet appel
pour une nouvelle renaissance depuis
assez longtemps première fois c'était à
singapour c'est un festival des
écrivains à singapour il ya déjà cinq
ans est depuis lors en asie au japon
taïwan en europe c'est l'italie la
france partout dans le monde cet appel
peut être donc relayé par d'autres
artistes je vous propose de découvrir
une nouvelle salle on y va d'accord
c'est bien c'est parti cette exposition
c'est quarante tableaux et dessins de
votre collection personnelle pour tenter
de rentrer dans votre univers des
oeuvres qui ont parfois plus de 40 ans
et même plus vous vous travaillez à
l'encré de chine
c'est un travail un petit peu à
l'inspiration plus qu préétabli oui ça
c'est le travail toujours appelé tôt
en écoutant la musique voilà il n'y a
pas de commanditaire ts qui salent
avance mais souvent c'est dans
l'improvisation tout en écoutant de la
musique
on a payé dans une ambiance a créé une
tension et d'image commence petit à
petit fait son apparition
vous cherchez à surprendre et est ce que
ça soit le spectateur qui sans vent qui
perçoivent quelque chose oui ça c'est
mon esthétique plutôt ça vient de mon
expérience de recherche
puisqu'on a tant fait pour la figuration
gao xing je vous vois regarder cette
oeuvre cette marée du soir que vous avez
réalisé on peut y voir un lien avec la
loire c'est ce c'est d'ailleurs devant
cette oeuvre que l'on se quitte la loire
qui coule au pied du château et regardez
cette merveilleuse perspective on se
quitte là dessus merci beaucoup d'avoir
être notre invité est on retrouve tout
de suite françois bonneau en 2007 le
domaine de chaumont-sur-loire appartient
à la région date à laquelle notre invité
a pris la présidence de la région
françois bonneau bonsoir merci d'être
avec nous ce soir bonsoir
cette année on fête les 500 ans de la
renaissance il ya un but un objectif
pour la région 500 ans de naissance 500
ans sur ce val de loire 500 en milieu de
ces châteaux 500 ans dans cette région
centre val de loire
c'est à l'évidence une identité qui se
confirme qui s'affirme pour notre
territoire régional
une identité faite de culture et de
nature une identité faite d'énergie une
identité faite de création et une
immense fierté d'accueillir comme nous
nous y préparons un très très très grand
nombre de visiteurs et un long travail
françois bonneau de deux années de
travail
deux années de travail pour permettre à
tous ces responsables de grands si de
petits sites à toutes ces collectivités
territoriales à tous ces acteurs ces
femmes ces hommes qui à travers l'art à
travers la culture donne vraiment un
visage à notre territoire
deux années de travail qui
ont été très vite reconnus par par
l'état un soutien de l'état qui ont été
très vite accompagné stéphane bern est
le parrain de cette opération et ça a
permis de préparer plus de 700
événements qui se déroulent tout au long
de cette année 2010 9 sur la totalité du
territoire et notamment bien évidemment
là où nous sommes sur les bords de la
loire
c'est énorme il ya un impact touristique
il y a un impact touristique bien
évidemment que nous sentons depuis le
lancement de cette saison avec de
formidables week end avec des semaines
qu'ils sont tout aussi plein avec des
manifestations qui rencontre un très
large public avec des tables qui sont
bien remplies sur des terrasses de nos
restaurants avec des silhouettes
honnêtement nous attendions bien
évidemment un résultat mais il est très
très très puissant et souvent au delà de
ce que nous attendions
on a des progressions qui sont
considérables je donne juste un exemple
sur la loire à vélo
nous étions l'an passé à un million cent
mille et bien sûr les premiers mois de
l'année nous augmentons de 40% les
utilisateurs de la loire à vélo
ce sont des gens qui viennent dans les
grands sites qui prennent le temps de
découvrir le fleuve
ce sont des gens qui vont découvrir
notre vignoble et nos visages et qui
bien évidemment font connaissance de la
région mais c'est important je parlais
de fear tiges parler d'identité c'est
important parce qu'on sait qu'il n'ya
pas de développement économique
s'il n'y a pas une attractivité du
territoire s'il n'y a pas une une
identité du territoire et la d'identité
de cette très belle région est en train
d'être perçue au niveau national et
international grâce à la renaissance ca
aussi du coup un impact économique mais
la renaissance c'est à la fois l'art et
la culture mais c'est aussi ce sont
aussi les sciences et des techniques
léonard c'est l'homme des sciences et
des techniques et aujourd'hui vivre la
renaissance faire partager la
renaissance c'est à l'évidence montré
que c'était ses terres de centre val de
loire est une terre pour le
développement économique pour la
recherche pour l'innovation c'est la
terre de aujourd'hui de ce grand grand
développement de la cosmétique de la
pharmacie etc
donc nous sommes vraiment très très
heureux merci de faire se rencontrer
notre culture et notre avenir
merci beaucoup françois bonneau
si on connaît donc le patrimoine l'art
et les jardins le festival internet
international desjardins
ça se passe à chaumont-sur-loire
regarder
[Musique]
bienvenue au paradis les dden du
festival des jardins justement consacré
à des visions de paradis pour sa 28e
édition
je suis benoît julienne et je suis
scénographe et bijoutiers
les équipes de créateurs ont oeuvré
depuis le début de l'année pour faire
surgir ces coins de paradis ancré dans
la terre de loire mais coloré mystérieux
comme ce mirage sorti d'un conte des
mille et une nuits nous on s'inspirer
des jardin persan entre du jardin de
bague est fine et et on a repris 1 le
plan des taxes d'état petit jardin
persan donc on a toute une gamme
chromatique dans les dents les pourpres
dans des bleus tu es dans des dents des
rouges des jaunes qui reprennent un peu
c'est ses gammes chromatiques dota tisse
un festival plus internationale que
jamais avec des américains des japonais
des coréens ou des vietnamiens des
voisins européens également comme le
collectif italien venu avec des
bananiers au nom prédestiné musa
paradisiaque a pourtant ces jardins sont
aussi le reflet de l'histoire et de
l'économie du val de loire les jardins
font intervenir plusieurs arts et
plusieurs métiers et notamment
évidemment le végétal la botanique donc
on travaille avec des pépinières des
pépinières spécialisées des pépinières
de collection est un des combats de
chaumont-sur-loire c'est de défendre la
filière horticole et la filière
horticole de notre région qui est très
intéressant en pariant sur l'alliance du
végétal et de la culture
chaumont-sur-loire renoue avec l'esprit
de la renaissance la période la plus
faste pour les créateurs de jardins
un reportage vous l'avez compris a
tourné il ya quelques jours puisque la
météo a complètement changé il pleut on
est abritée sous une voiture accompagné
de bernard lassus ce bon soir est-ce que
vous pouvez m'expliquer en quoi vous
êtes un autre particulier dans ce
domaine de chaumont-sur-loire bernard je
suis un homme particulier parce que
j'apporte principalement de la couleur
et que ce sont des jardins pérenne et je
remercie madame claude dumont mais je
suis très content d'être dans ce jeu
dans ce lieu prestigieux parce que les
jardins qui sont ici sont des jardins
expérimentaux pour le paysage de demain
demain nous serons 1,9 ou 2 milliards
sur la terre il faut par conséquent
prévoir de nouveaux aménagements
il n'y a pas que préserver la nature il
ya réinventer ce qui doit nous entoure
et c'est votre rôle aussi c'est ce que
vous avez essayé de faire c'est ce que
j'essaie ici de montrer des hypothèses
de travail sur l'invention d'un nouveau
paysage pour demain on voit un nouveau
jardin derrière c'est magnifique vous
êtes carte verte ici expliquez nous en
quoi cela consiste-t-il bien c'est une
invitation qui me laisse le choix
personnel de faire ce que j'ai envie de
faire on m'a mis à ma disposition un un
espace un lieu que je dois justement
transformé en espace
hier c'était beaucoup de travail allez
certainement cdc des pièces tout à fait
et je dois dire que le travail a été
long parce que d'ailleurs aujourd'hui où
il ya du vent nous voyons bien que le
coc des surfaces comme celles ci doivent
pouvoir soutenir le vent y avait le
pardon message derrière ces jardins alsh
et surtout qu'il va falloir trouver de
nouveaux espaces et que la couleur est
notre ami quelle couleur vous avez voulu
utiliser toutes les couleurs vous avez
mis combien de temps pour ce jardin où
ces jardins hausse et des jardins que
j'ai étudié depuis plusieurs années et
la construction la réalisation s'est
réalisée sur place plusieurs semaines
merci beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité
bernard la suisse